Malcolm Jenkins good to see you sir
always you bet and so the fact that you
are here allows you to rearrange my set
dressing yeah if you will I always have
this just one item on my desk that has
nothing to do with the actual
preparation or execution of the show and
it's my mini Michigan helmet that's to
my left you have now placed a mini Ohio
State helmet got to balance it out I
mean cuz you know everybody else can see
you got Michigan paraphernalia
everywhere that's true and I felt I was
very uncomfortable I would call a gear
instead of paraphernalia you know I you
know I would call it so I was in a
dressing room yeah there's like this
bowl that has keys and wallets and like
paper clips and yeah change looks like
people just discard things into it is
that supposed to be the big house they
just in fact the big house yes it is a
bowl where things get discarded I
haven't really thought of it that way
I haven't really thought of it that way
how does a kid from Jersey wind up at
the Ohio State University Malcolm
Jenkins
so grew up in pescado in New Jersey my
aunt moved to Westerville Ohio maybe my
sophomore year in high school and so one
summer we decided to go visit so we're
there for two weeks and my parents paid
for myself my brother and friend of mine
to go to Ohio State's four-day camp I
didn't know that like if you're a
recruit that you don't have to pay to go
to these camps but we paid and they were
like why reciever DB one-on-one drills
and I started kind of in the line that
had like the least amount of competition
so I kind of dominated there so I went
to the next line to the next line and
eventually I just made myself down to
where I saw all the coaches paying
attention with all of these the best
receivers so all their top recruits like
Brian Hartline was there but basically
all these guys and I just like kept
competing and any time a defensive back
with a corner would hesitate to go out
or they were nervous I just jump out in
front of them and so I would do two
three four reps in a row
Mel Tucker was the DB coach at the time
or he might have been a D coordinator
and he pulled me to the side and said
you know he's like you know what's your
name
I said Malcolm he's saying you might be
the best corner in the country and I was
a one star recruit at the time and so we
went in the back and we'd watch some
some of my tape and by the time I got
back to Jersey I had an offer from house
there's no kidding and so who else
offered you I said at that point in time
I only had an offer from Rutgers that
literally played in their backyard
backyard yeah yeah and then Ohio State
was the second one and I think just
because of house they offer me I got an
offer from VTech in Syracuse in Indiana
so the fact that Ohio State was first
you felt comfortable having been at that
camp your aunt was living in Ohio that
was the end of that [ __ ] put made it it
came down to three schools V Tech
Rutgers and Ohio State I went to visit
Virginia Tech which was my grandmother
lived maybe two hours from there
so his Beamer there at the time yes okay
and before I got into the meeting with
Beamer the DB coach at a time as we're
walking down the hall he's like okay now
we've offered six corners we're gonna
take the first two that that commit so
make sure you know you go in there and
give give coach a good impression and so
that kind of rubbed me the wrong way I
like you really don't want me just want
two corners so I took them off the list
and then it came down to Rutgers and
Ohio State Schiano had just got the
Rutgers and the only reason I didn't go
there was because I didn't like that
Schiano
only recruited his skilled positions
from Florida at that time he was just
coming from Miami and so he had this
whole stigma that you know all the
skilled position you know that the best
guys were in Florida and so he skipped
over a ton of guys that were in Jersey
at the time and so I ended up at Ohio
State
I mean Jersey is one of the top states
in the United States weed for football
we don't get enough credit I tell people
I think in my in in my drive class we in
the first round we had at least seven
first rounders from Jersey there were
all my senior class because people
mentioned Florida and Texas and you know
California is another state Jersey's a
sneaky ball stay
when I was drafted we had it was myself
Kyle Wilson ended up being a first-round
draft pick
we had Knowshon Moreno BJ Rossi Shawn
green EJ racha racha Island Brian
Cushing sure
Eugene Monroe was running at time doing
Jerry Kenny Britt and both of McCourty
twins all of us were in the same same
high school so being in Philly right now
you must have a ton of family that's
coming to see you play my family's about
an hour away
yeah man Philly is practically in New
Jersey right across the suburb yeah you
know one will say that they wouldn't say
that pissing them off right I understand
that I understand that Malcolm Jenkins
here on the Rich Eisen show just a quick
macro question for you before we start
drilling deeper you won with the Saints
you've won with the Eagles what makes a
Super Bowl champion in your estimation
like is there is there a formula
something a fan can think about or a
player knows needs to be on a team what
do you want
it starts with a culture first if you
don't have a winning culture meaning
that you you have from top down from
coaches to every player on the roster
everybody is bought into what you're
doing
in in the smallest ways and that and
it's not you're not having to be
directed by everybody so if there's an
issue if your locker room can handle it
within the locker room without ever
having to be you know coach thing then
you you know you've kind of established
some type of culture secondly you got to
have the talent but then I think the the
two other things that really are kind of
out of your control is you got to stay
healthy and then you got to come up with
a little bit of luck and so I can
remember when we played the Dolphins
when I was in New Orleans we were down
on over 21 points or something like that
and ended up coming back and winning
that game we played in the Redskins and
tight game we're on the road we're
losing and drew Brees throws a pick and
then Robert Meachem strips the guy and
it runs it for attention I remember that
yeah
and so like games like that will
supposed to win but we did you know that
kind of prepare you even in with Philly
that you know the game we're throwing in
a playing the Falcons the D be supposed
to could have been an easy interception
it bounces off his knee and then Torrey
Smith catches it off the deflection like
things like that you know tend to happen
there's a little bit of luck but you
know when you have the talent you have
the culture you always get yourself a
chance then you also have to have those
button-pushing moments to both your
coaches for you supervillains made some
ridiculous calls my specialty
ridiculously cojones filled calls
definitely what was it like in the
locker room when Sean Payton said we're
gonna go onside kick to start the second
half for that Super Bowl so I think it's
like you know both coaches I think
understood like who we were right and so
we were playing the Colts and you know
man who was eating everybody up we knew
going into that game we needed to steal
two possessions if we can do that we can
score with them and we win and so the
very first one we two weeks before the
Super Bowl we said are we gonna put in
this kick practice it over and over and
over and over and we go in and halftime
he's like hey how do I feel about it and
everybody's like let's do it and so we
come out we get it that was the first
possession we stole and then the second
one was Tracy yeah so he took the
temperature of the locker room
I mean he's like hey how do you guys
feel about it
everybody's like running right all right
let's go
same thing you know and we played the
Patriots we knew they were gonna the
Philly special yeah we know they were
gonna go and everyone's score points for
us on defense it got to the point where
like we just need one stop and then if
our offers can keep you know doing stuff
that that fairly special obviously as
wanted a gutsy his plays in Super Bowl
history but paid off it's amazing you
were there you were there football I
mean you could you could say gutsiest
calls in the history the Super Bowl we
just talked about one two you could even
argue which ones one and which ones -
yeah in the history of that you know
yeah we're not thinking about it yeah I
mean I was just you know I was on the
field for one he's on the sideline for
other just kind of watching especially
on the sideline yeah right and I didn't
know what they were gonna run did not
and I hadn't even seen them practice it
really yeah so I didn't even know where
it came from so you were like a fan in
the stadium where's like where the hell
did that come from I mean it's a copycat
league the Patriots ran that play
against us a couple years before we
played them right in the Superbowl Tom
Cotter and then did it again in Super
Bowl and obviously Tom didn't catch it
that time thank God Malcolm Jenkins here
on the Rich Eisen show all right let's
uh a couple quick hitters here
instant replay now includes pass
interference you're already shaking your
head I mean anything in slow motion is
going to like pass interference you know
so I think you know it's like any other
rule change
we'll see what happens in the preseason
usually they'll call ridiculous calls in
the preseason fans and players will
complain and by the time we get to the
regular season they'll figure out the
kinks but I think you know you look at
situations like criticals moments in a
game where a ball grows up and then a
guy on the other side of the field might
be committing passing offense but the
ball is not going to miss on the other
side but you can challenge anybody on
the field I think that makes it that
makes it tough you know and when you're
when you start calling things that
actually have no no effect on what the
play was my obviously if you get a
blatant call like you had in New Orleans
you want to be able to rectify that but
I think that was also it was so blatant
that that's just a bad call and so to
change all that the rules for one
instance I think makes makes game I
think it makes a little bit tougher well
I mean the head of NFL ruffs al River on
who's gonna be here a week from tomorrow
he went to the he's going around all the
networks he stopped by the NFL Media
Group back in June if you recall a
Thursday Night Football game between the
Chargers and the Chiefs where they won
with no time left on a two-point
conversion if you remember to mind
Williams is wide open drunk pretty much
ran the same play that they used to
score touchdowns yeah that was set up by
a defensive pass interference call in
the end zone that if they had reviewed
it they would not have been able to
change that call but they would have
under review caught
the offensive pass interference call
that was not called would have waved it
off as offsetting penalties do you like
that as a defender that now OPI might be
raised to a certain level that hasn't
been raised before I'm very skeptical
that every time they change the rule
they make it sound like they pitch it to
defensive guys I know we'll call it for
you guys too and it never happened you
don't believe it so the helmet rule that
we put in last time is really really
strict really hard on defenders to to
try to move and hit a moving target but
we understand the the the gist of the
rule we're trying to accomplish but it's
pitch to watch to like oh no it can be
on offensive guys too and I might have
seen it call twice where you know a
running back comes through and just
literally runs the guy over you know
what his head that happens almost on
every play but it's rarely ever called
unless it's really blatant and so it
sounds good but we really don't get
offensive pass interference called as it
is I don't know if you want coaches
challenging you know those type of plays
because oftentimes it's still gonna be
arbitrary is are you looking at because
the rule for those pick plays is it a
yard down the field if it's within a
yard then it's legal to be picked but if
it's not and so I don't know I think it
slows down the game
I think players are smart enough to to
you know play the game we've been
playing for a long time I think the rest
would just make the calls Malcolm
Jenkins here on the Rich Eisen show what
would you as the NFL and NFL PA sitting
down apparently there was a chat
yesterday that both sides called
productive what would you want to see in
the collective bargaining agreement from
your perspective yeah I mean for me
there's a ton of things I mean you know
there's there's a lot of things that are
in question that we want to learn more
about there's this new sports gambling
you know sports betting all those things
there's a new stream of revenue that's
that's out there that I think we need to
be diligent about figuring out how that
split is I think I know a big concern
for guys is just like medical care for
for you know lifetime we put our bodies
on the line and guys are
dealing with some serious medical issues
once they leave the game and to be able
to have resources and not you know
struggle to get help
we're trying to eradicate that I think
you know for me you know guys talk about
guarantee contracts I don't think in our
game that it'll help if every single
player had a guaranteed contract but I
think we do need to work more guarantees
into the way our contracts are
structured and I think the biggest thing
for me as I look at what we did last
time and moving forward is just the
restrictions that we have on our young
playmakers in the league so if you're
you know we we made this rookie rate
scale and thought that okay that money
will get pushed into the middle class of
the league and in fact it just made
Rockies cheaper and all the money really
stays at the top of the league as far as
players and and it makes it really
really hard on our young talent like say
Kwan Barclays Odell Beckham's who come
into the league and within two years
they're the best at their position but
didn't they're restricted because their
contracts are four or five years so a
team could essentially use you and keep
you under your rookie deal for seven
years they can extend your use the 50
year option which is the average of the
third highest paid player into a
position in the 25th mm-hmm so that's a
huge drop and then they're the franchise
tags and then they can get tagged twice
after that and so to me it's about how
do we get those players who are our
market drivers who are you know the
faces of the new faces of the league to
free-agency faster or to you know the
ability knowing that now in the NFL
career is shrunk even more in its 2.6
years right so essentially you're using
players on their rookie deal keeping
them on a rookie deal to the prime of
their career where they were able to
make the most money and so we want to be
able to get guys out of that so do you
think there's room for movement on
something like that do you think cuz
that I mean that's that's a lot of math
right there that you just threw out but
I understand it you know I totally hear
you and you know we just saw the NBA
free agency
never once
like well why can't NFL free agency be
like that I'm like well could you
imagine if the Raptors had a franchise
tag yeah well I would have gone nowhere
right right this so I mean like that
that's for starters
okay I mean you can't that's for
absolute starters so his franchise tags
in your estimation that should be on the
table because I know that affects a very
top 1% you just described how it does
create a dominant certain tags are fine
is is more so for these rookies who are
like I said your deal if you're playing
well is going to get extended to five
years then they can tag you twice after
that and so you're literally you don't
get to free-agency until your eighth
year possibly potentially if a team
didn't want to you know security long
term and so I think that's that's one of
the things and then when it comes to
guaranteed money I think one of the
things that are that we don't
necessarily understand and talk about
enough is that the NBA and all these
other leagues they don't have mandatory
contracts in their CBA's so it's not
mandatory the guarantee contracts and so
for us I think we as players where we
kind of do ourselves a disservice is
we're able to collude so if I'm one of
if I'm afraid to see I'm a free agent
and I know another guys at a free agent
another guy we can all call each other
and say look we're not gonna sign
anything unless it's guaranteed the
owners cannot do that they collude it's
a violation in the CBA but unfortunately
we don't exercise that that power I
think enough to just mandate it and
start those trends but I think is well
within our rights to one change how our
contracts are structured in a CBA but
also as players kind of exercising
leverage that we have right now why
don't you if you don't mind son my the
ohio state helmet that will be here
forevermore that's always here on the
set well at the very same time so you
pointed out across the way the bust that
has been here that was created along
with our set that's me you thought that
was Bo Schembechler figured it was Bo
Steinbach right cuz you saw a Michigan
hat on top of it well I was just I was
setting up a joke to say he started at
Ohio State
you know there's no but oh let's not be
very cavalier with facts he we started
at Miami of Oaxaca where he coached with
Woody Hayes there there you go so he's a
Woody Hayes disciple you're right but
it's okay there's another house eight at
all never
you sure Miami of Ohio okay and I said
that that is actually my old hat from
college that I had Jim Harbaugh signed
when he stopped by here and you said
what did you say then I was like it
first I said Michigan people weird
that's what you said and then I said is
that is like the college had a thing
like no it's not just like I had it in
college I've always kept it and I
figured why not just take it out of
service and have the coach who is my
quarterback freshman year sign pole for
everybody in the studio right now is
anybody have a hat in their possession
that they had in college no okay so if
you want to talk about weird though that
would be the equivalent of meet likes
having a sweater vest because I play for
Jim Tressel and I was like this is nice
this is my college sweater this that I
will always keep but the weird thing is
you would call it the sweater vest be
what's with thee it's one talk about
weird it's the it's not like we confuse
it with another Ohio State University
first off it's in the actual name of the
school so it's not like we're making it
up right it's literally the Ohio State
University right the Malcolm Jenkins
foundation you know oh it's not why
there's it's like I was just gonna call
go to Malcolm Jenkins foundation.org but
it's no the doing some good for so many
people I would have to make fun of that
no you gotta keep doing good community
works through the Malcolm Jenkins
foundation org the quarterback of the
Philadelphia Eagles Carson Wentz how's
he doing he's no good he's good um you
know had a good spring I think he's
confident he's throwing the ball well
okay he's we're covered and everything
so where did all those unnamed quotes
from that piece that Rose run a couple
years ago come from that he's not
popular within the lock
no I think that was eventually vigilante
uh you know reporter of trying to get
some some likes I think you know it's
one of those things when we had a weird
situation where you have a carson wentz
and a nick foles in the same locker room
yep and so of course the questions that
come is who do you prefer who do you
like more
and i think they do have two different
personalities but you know carson as a
teammate is a great guy comes in he's
somebody who's not he's a quarterback
who doesn't try to act like he's the
leader or the quarterback would be vocal
just because he plays that position he's
had the opportunity to come in as a
young guy and grow into a little bit of
a leadership piece you know he's a guy
who likes the outdoors he doesn't
necessarily like the city life so he's
not one that's gonna be partying with
guys but you know he's a great teammate
is there for you so a lot of the stuff
was was overblown yeah he went to the
North Dakota State University yeah I
don't know if they were qualify for addy
but okay alright he went to North Dakota
so um
because those sorts of things where
there's multiple quarterbacks who are
successful in the locker room can can
create factions who was policing that or
did it require any policing I guess I
don't think it required any you know
doesn't happen because uh well when
whenever Nick was in there Carson wasn't
available so it's not like we had both
of them and in they're competing for a
job and Camp him and you got half the
team that's saying hey we want him to be
the starter and my team you know it was
we went into the season in both seasons
really knowing Carson is our quarterback
and then Carson gets injured and we feel
really good about Nick being our
quarterback you know I am their own now
and so uh that's a great problem to have
we try not to let you know outside
voices you know penetrate our locker
rooms a pretty tight group and I think
we've handled that you know pretty well
as best we can as a team so the goal is
what win Super Bowl yeah okay
yeah cuz sometimes it's difficult for a
player just come out and put that on the
table no I mean the goal if you know if
your goal is not the winners who will
well then I guess what needs to happen
for you to win the Super Bowl this year
well I I'm never one to think that you
you show up and win and so for us I
think on paper right now this preseason
potential that we have things look great
but that changes you know you don't know
what you have until you step out of
training camp and so for us you know we
got a pretty tough schedule and I think
as long as we can stay healthy I think
we can play with anybody in the league
it's just about really winning the games
that you're supposed to win just find a
way to get a couple that you aren't yep
um just put yourself in position in a
division first that guarantees respond
to the tournament and then you know from
there you're working on positioning but
we focus on our division just to get
into the tournament it would feel like
we'll be in a good spot later down the
road got three minutes left Brockman
read the quote from Jim Harbaugh today
that was said uttered by the coach the
University of Michigan go for it
Jim cow a commie did a podcast with Jim
Harbaugh asked him about Urban Meyer
Urban's had a winning record a really
phenomenal record everywhere he's been
but also controversy follows everywhere
he's been
your thoughts Malcolm yeah winners
attract attention nobody's he hasn't had
a controversy besides with his dress
code or something horrible are you
talking to me I mean you know when
you're winning you get attention your
cameras people want to know now comes
implying that Jim Harbaugh isn't winning
yeah basically that's what he didn't
hear that I was applying that Jim
Harbaugh isn't winning yes so there's no
controversy I heard that besides his job
security I'm sorry it's my guests
talking right now oh great
and before I let you go the Malcolm
Jenkins foundation org is how you can
get involved with everything that you
are doing but real quick you and Chris
Long helped a law come in to be the
clean slate Act what is that yeah so a
couple thing I don't know two years ago
maybe myself Torrey Smith and Chris long
took a trip down to Harrisburg PA to
lobby for a piece of legislation called
the clean slate Act and what that does
is you know we once we found out that
one in three people have some type of
criminal record and all the effects of
that means that you sometimes get
discriminated against
housing for education for business loans
all type of things hard to get a job and
so you got a one-third of the population
that's dealing with those type of
restrictions for small you know things
and so this piece of legislation
basically after 10 years automatically
cleans up or wipes away or seals
someone's record for non-violent
misdemeanors
so they don't have to petition for it
they don't have to do anything as long
as they don't violate for a 10-year
period
it's just off of their record and it
gets people you know it's not it's not a
fix-all but it gets people you know back
to being productive citizens to be able
to get kind of a scarlet letter offer
their life for things they've done you
know the small things that they've done
maybe in their youth you want to get
that politics when you're done no not
really
I'd like to put pressure on elected
officials I don't necessarily want to be
one okay Malcolm Jenkins I really
appreciate you coming by here sir as you
know I root for you with the exception
of one Saturday in November every single
year and I appreciate it I know you
appreciate that I give you a hard time a
lot and you keep it pretty professional
it's impressive
well you could keep you can upgrade the
allot to all the time by the way you're
kind of you know downplaying the amount
of grief that I get but at some point
you know it turns I'm waiting for word
to turn the writing on the rivalry is I
just want y'all to make a closed-off
stop that is the worst most backhanded
insult you could possibly give which is
why you just delivered a dying
it is not dying it used to be one of the
greatest in sports oh gosh but you know
when you you won for like a decade and a
half now all right Malcolm it's no time
for you to go promote the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on VR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app